[Musica]
da quando ho iniziato a riflettere su
come strutturare questo tokyo il primo
pensiero è stato quello di non avere
persone e di conseguenza avere uno
spazio ridimensionato la causa è una
pandemia una pandemia globale che ha
sovvertito il quotidiano di fronte a
questo noi potevamo fare solo due cose o
subire o reagire con resilienza
presidenza nel suo più ampio significato
cioè assorbo il colpo e spero l'ostacolo
questa resilienza ciò che ha
caratterizzato un gruppo di ragazzi che
tanti anni fa sono partiti dal sud
italia per andare a lavorare in altre
parti d'italia nel mondo e che durante
il periodo della pandemia sono ritornati
hanno deciso di rimanere lavorare da lì
combattere per un territorio che deve
essere riconfigurato nasce in questo
modo south working ed è bene specificare
che south non vuol dire solo sud italia
certo il progetto nasce per quello nasce
per rivalutare il territorio che da anni
subisce un forte spopolamento
ma quando parliamo di studio parliamo di
sud relativo che è un valore inserito
nella carta dei valori del software dic
e questo vuol dire che il concetto è
applicabile alla sicilia così come la
lombardia così come al trentino
e questo per un unico motivo siamo tutti
il sud di qualcun altro per poter
parlare di south working bene dare una
serie di numeri e talenti motion ci
viene in aiuto
si dice che sono 84 mila i ragazzi che
oggi dall'italia sono andati via sono
andati all'estero e questo per noi è un
costo molto elevato parliamo di 14
miliardi di euro circa l'un per cento
del nostro prodotto interno lordo e
queste sono cifre molto molto
preoccupanti e in un certo senso anche
molto molto tristi in italia sono oltre
due milioni di ragazzi che verso
l'italia si sono mossi verso altre parti
attualmente presso naturali e tutto
questo e molto triste perché se io penso
che per ricercare una mia gratificazione
personale economica devo andare pulsi
lontanta cento di abitudini centro di
vita centro di affetti e questo mi rende
molto triste
savona vuole inserirsi esattamente qui
invertire il senso di rotta quindi
lottare per questi territori attraendo
capitale umano e di conseguenza capitale
economico cercando di andare a ridurre
quello che è vario che ormai segna
lentamente la differenza fra nord e sud
italia oggi parlando di south working di
quelli che saranno gli effetti di south
working possiamo tracciare una linea che
parte dall individuo passa per le
aziende e va nelle città
l'individuo ha già ridimensionato il
proprio spazio già da un po di tempo
lavora non più negli uffici lavora da
casa lavora nei presidi di comunità e
questa è una cosa molto importante
perché non ha più a che fare con i
colleghi ma con south worker che
arrivano da tutto il mondo e che
condividono non solo uno spazio
lavorativo ma anche un una miscela di
esperienze che arricchisce il bagaglio
culturale di ogni singolo individuo
questo cambiamento del dell'individuo a
impatto naturalmente anche sulle aziende
perché le aziende non hanno più bisogno
di avere tutti i giorni in ufficio i
dipendenti e questo tipo di questo tipo
di modifica farà sì e questo ce lo dice
uno studio condotto da mike in sei che
noi torneremo in azienda ma torneremo in
azienda con
un equilibrio gestiremo un po di lavoro
in modalità agile è un po di lavoro in
ufficio
saranno le attività più proficue quelle
che rimarranno in ufficio o attività in
cui sarà richiesto di avere accesso a
documenti mentre tutte le attività più
routinarie più diciamo così che si
possono svolgere in singolo acco saranno
svolti in modalità agile e le aziende a
seguito di questo ridurranno
notevolmente gli uffici in favore di una
forte espansione delle aree aree comuni
aree comuni che diventeranno il 60 e 70
per cento di un'azienda e non solo
destinate a attività di tipo lavorativo
o brainstorming saranno destinati ad
aree di relax perché molti per esempio
degli uffici oggi a milano sono stati
già riadattati molti degli uffici di
milano oggi sono sale yoga massaggi
molti sono diventate delle terrazze
delle terrazze in cui dipendenti
utilizzano il loro tempo libero e questo
lavoro che viene svolto non più in
azienda diventa così forte così
importante che anche il motore di
ricerca più importante al mondo di
ricerca lavorativa linkedin a un certo
punto della pandemia inserisce un nuovo
filtro lavoro a distanza
questo cambiamento sull'azienda si
riversa ulteriormente poi sulla città le
città ad oggi vivono nel centro la loro
economia il centro storico diventa
spesso il centro economico della città
ma questo non sarà più così ci sarà uno
svuotamento i lavoratori che non devono
più andare in ufficio si sposteranno
resteranno dalle loro a lavorare dalle
loro abitazioni o nei presidi di
comunità e questo farà sì che si
riattiveranno ci sarà una nuova linfa
vitale per le attività che abitano le
periferie quindi tutti quei quartieri
che oggi sono cosiddetti quartieri
dormitorio torneranno a vivere questo
fenomeno è così importante che assume un
nome il politecnico di milano lo
definisce networking sono città 15
minuti
tra l'abitazione e l'ufficio vengono
inseriti dei presidi di comunità dai
quali i software per possono lavorare e
rimanendo in quella zona continuare a
consumare negli esercizi e rilanciare in
questo modo quelle che sono le economie
di prossimità
questa è un'analisi che ci arriva da
dallo studio dell'ultima pandemia
soprattutto in cui abbiamo visto che gli
esercizi presenti nelle periferie sono
quelli che hanno sofferto meno e questa
è un'eredità molto importante che
dobbiamo tenere e portare avanti in
questa ridefinizione delle città si
inseriscono propri presidi imprese di di
comunità presidi di comunità
fondamentalmente sono spazi di lavoro
che cercano di combattere l'isolamento
domestico e che in accordo con i comuni
e con le istituzioni si stanno
diffondendo sempre di più
io sono nato qui sono nato a vicenza e
mi sono trasferito a milano da circa 5
anni dove lavoro per una multinazionale
all'inizio di quest'anno però mi sono
trasferito mi sono trasferito in sicilia
nella terra natia dei miei genitori che
santo stefano di camastra città delle
ceramiche dove in accordo con il comune
ho avuto la possibilità di gestire un
presidio di comunità di portare avanti
un progetto di presidio di comunità
abbiamo riadattato le sale di un palazzo
un palazzo costruito fra il 1600 e il
1700 che si chiama palazzo tra via e
dotandolo di tutti i servizi che
permettono agli autori per di lavorare
siamo riusciti a rendere un luogo che è
ricco di affreschi di pavimenti ceramici
che si affaccia sulle oli un vero e
proprio luogo di raccolta di questi
southwark a seguito di una serie di
accordi col comune relativi al servizi
per le famiglie per esempio quindi
benefit relativi alla xi agli asili
asili nido scuole
siamo riusciti ad avere dei south worker
per medio breve termine ma siamo stati
anche in grado di avere delle nuove
persone di nuovi cittadini software che
era medio lungo termine quindi oggi
abbiamo tre nuovi cittadini una coppia
di ragazzi che ha vissuto l'ultimo
decennio in sudafrica lei oggi lavora in
regime di south working e lui ha
implementato una nuova attività
economica a santo stefano di camastra e
questa è una cosa molto molto importante
e poi un ragazzo che arriva dall'america
ha sempre gestito la sua società di
investimenti immobiliari fra la florida
new york los angeles e oggi ha trovato
una sua dimensione in sicilia oltre che
la sua cittadinanza italiana
quindi fondamentalmente è proprio questo
che fa south orleans at work in cerca di
raccogliere i semi di una nuova società
e cerca di ricostruirla una società
molto più moderna molto più inclusiva e
quindi fondamentalmente adottando una
serie di misure orientate verso la
costruzione di nuovi presidi di comunità
orientate verso una serie di benefici di
tipo contributivo di tipo fiscale per le
aziende che permettono ai software per
di lavorare in regime di soft walking
favorendo l'implementazione di nuovi
servizi infrastrutture tecnologiche e
servizi di trasporto e una serie di
benefit per le famiglie dei software che
noi crediamo fortemente che south
warning possa ridisegnare un nuovo mondo
realizzabile noi crediamo fortemente che
south working possa davvero essere una
soluzione vincente alla ridefinizione
dello spazio grazie
[Applauso]